creating a texture atlas is actually a
very tricky engineering task texture
packing is a type of bin packing problem
that has been proved to be np hard the
problem is so challenging that i
frequently use a variant of this
algorithm as an interview question to
evaluate the skill of potential hires
grits rather than writing our own
version of texture packing grits uses
texture packer which is a great
off-the-shelf tool that fits into most
content pipelines quickly it will
generate the atlas data given a list of
loose textures alongside a data file
that maps the individual source images
to their final locations in the atlas